[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في النقاش يمكنكم كالعاده ان
تتفاعلون مع ما يقولون ضيوف البرنامج على
صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج
على تويتر في النقاش الموجه الحمراء التي
توقعتها عمليه استطلاع الراي في
الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه لم تحصل الجمهوريون كسبوا مجلس
النواب بسهوله ولكن الفرق حتى الان ضيق في
مجلس الشيوخ وبعيد انقذ الموقف حسب
المحللين والمعلقين الامريكيين سنحاول
القراءه في هذه النتائج مع ذوي الاختصاص
ولو ان نتائج ليست نهائيه وهناك انتخابات
ستؤجل الى شهر ديسمبر المقبل هل هذا يعني
ان التصويت الشباب لعب دورا في تغيير
النتائج الى اي حد هي نتائج تعكس تراجع
الفكر المتطرف عند الجمهوريين كيف ستؤثر
هذه النتائج على السياسه الامريكيه
الداخليه وخارجيا سعيد بان يناقش هذا
الموضوع مع مرح البقعي من واشنطن وهي عضو
الحزب الجمهوري ومديره مكتب صحيفه
الدوليه سعيد بان يكون ان تكون معي من
كانزاس ناديه عويدات وهي عضو الحزب
الديمقراطي واستاذه في جامعه ولايه كانساس
وسعيد ايضا بان يكون معي من واشنطن حافظ
لغوين وهو زميل في معهد الدراسات الدوليه
في جامعه جونس هوبكنز اهلا وسهلا بكم في
هذا البرنامج التفاعلي ونحن بحاجه طبعا
الى ارائكم ولكن نبدا قبل ذلك ونستمع لما
قاله ترامب
يا لهوي
تلك التي حققناها
الموجوده
وثلاثه خسائر هل هذا جيد
ونستمع الى حاكم فلوريدا الجمهوري رن
ديسانتس الذي فاز للمره الثانيه
لقد عانقنا الحريه
حافظنا على القانون والنظام العام وقمنا
بحمايه حقوق الوالدين واحترمنا دافع
الضرائب اليوم وبعد اربع سنوات في السلطه
اصدر الناس حكمهم مجددا الحريه ستظل في
فلوريدا
وماذا
ام فارس
حق المراه في الاختيار رفع الحد الادنى
للاجور النظام من اجل العمل النقابي
الرعايه الصحيه من حقوق الانسان لان ذلك
انقذ حياتي
[موسيقى]
تم الاستعداد لكي نرى موجه حمراء لا سابق
لها في تاريخ الانتخابات النصفيه واذا بها
موجه نكد نقول برتغاليه لم نقل رماديا
نوعا ما يعني بين الاحمر والازرق
مساء الخير يا عزيزي يعني هي حمراء ليست
برتقاليه
ولكنها ليست يعني بالحجم الذي كان متوقعا
وهذا حقيقي
لاعلق قليلا على ما سمعت بالتقرير اولا
انت تعرف تماما موقفي من موضوع
ترامبزم
الحزب الجمهوري ليس الرئيس الاسبق ترامب
الرئيس الاسبق ترامب ات- ظاهره ظاهره مهمه
وتغييريه في الفكر السياسي
لكنه ليس الحزم
معناها في الحمله
ساعرج على هذه النقطه وهذه نقطه مهمه جدا
ان مثلا لنقل سيره
هوكا بي التي فازت لاول مره اول امراه
تكون
غافرنر في وكاله او تنسى ابتعدت تماما عن
الرئيس ترامب مع انها كانت الناطقه
الرسميه باسم البيت الابيض في عهد الرئيس
ترامب لم ياتي الى حملاتها الانتخابيه لم
تستعن به وحاولت ان تفصل نفسها سياسيا عنه
تماما انا ارى ان من دعمهم الرئيس ترامب
لم يستطيع الوصول الى الفوز المطلوب هذا
يعني ما يزال الرئيس ترامب للاسف يرتبط
صورته شخصيا باحداث السادس من جانوري في
امريكا التي تركت اثرا صعب جدا لكن اعود
اقول لحزب الجمهوري ليس الرئيس ترامب ونحن
نراه يتقدم يعني سائق اخذ الاغلبيه وهذا
المهم هذا جزء اساسي من المبدا شكس اند
فالنسس في الحياه السياسيه الامريكيه همم
وهو مبدا يتعلق بفص السلطات يتعلق بعدم
ترك سلطه معينه تستفرد بالراي لفتره طويله
يعود التوازن الان ب همم ان شاء الله
الاغلبيه ستكون في المجلسين لجمهوريين طيب
همم فرح سهلت عليه كلمه مروريه ترامب هو
المشكله يعني ههه
واحده هو المشكله همم
الحزب الجمهوري هو من انتخبت ترامب الحزب
الجمهوري هو من ساعد ترامب على
تعيين ال- ال- القضاه لكي يقرر ان المراه
ليس لها حق ان تفعل بجسدها ما تريد وهذا
ادى الى
عدم حدوث الحمراء وقد اختلف مع
ما راح هي تقول ان هناك
والانتخابات كما قلت ان تفرق في بدايه
البرنامج لم تحسن بعد لا نستطيع ان نقول
ان الحزب الجمهوري فاس ولكن
الشعب الامريكي همم قال كلمته انه مع
الديمقراطيه انه يريد للمراه ان يكون لها
حق التصويت على جسدها
حتى في ولايات حيث اتواجد الان في ولايه
كنزه وهي وهي ولايه محافظه
جمهوري ليس هذه
السياسه
من الدول العربيه واحده فقط
جميع من يريدون ديمقراطيه حول العالم
وخصوصا في الشرق الاوسط
تماما تماما اذا ليس ليست الديمقراطيه
حكرا على الحزب الديمقراطي هي جزء من
الحياه الامريكيه
الرئيس بعيدها حاول ان يحتكر حاول رئيس
يعني غلط غلطه كبيره كثير بالحياه
الامريكيه ولا بالنسبه للشعب الامريكي
حاول ان يقول ان الجمهوريين ضد
الديمقراطيه يحطمون الديمقراطيه هذا الشيء
كثير يعني صعب نفهمه المواطن الامريكي
وحتى انا وانت سيده ناديه من المهاجرين
طيب طيب
اوكي
ستلعب دور هتدور بين الحزب بين الجمهوري
والدبوقراطي اتفضل في قراءه النتائج ولو
انها ليست نهايه تفضل شكرا يا اخوي يا
توفيق ومرحبا اي نعم مع حريه المراه وانا
اعرف قوتها يعني ههه مرحبا مرحبا
الاساس اللي هي انا اريد ان اركز على
نقطتين قالتهم مرح وقالتهم همم
الجمهوري لا يمكن حسره في الترامب
ترامب والمجموعه المتطرفه التي استطاع ان
يكونها في داخل الحزب الجمهوري يعني همه
تاريخيا
ومنطقيا هم اقرب من المختطفين لفكره الحزب
الجمهوري اعتقد ان هذه الانتخابات اظهرت
جديد ان هناك حزب جمهوري معتدل ولذلك لم
يذهبوا ولم يؤيدوا
الشخصيات التي ايدها ترامب بالطريقه التي
كان يتصورها الكثيرين وهذه علامه ايجابيه
جدا من الناحيه الاخرى
اعتقد ان المشكله مش بس في ترامب ولكن
اتفق مع الدكتور ناديه ان المشكله ايضا في
الحزب الجمهوري نفسه الذي سمح لي ترامب
وسامح للمجموعه المتطرفه ان تخطف تاريخه
الطويل وانت همم يعني همم تصغر من حجمه
وتجعل حزب يظهر للج- للناس بانه حزب عنصري
حزب متطرف حزب يرفض الاخر حزب يحاول تقييد
الحريات حريه المراه في الاجهاض كان سبب
اساسي همم عدم قدره الجمهوريين ان ينتصروا
في في هذه الانتخابات ال- همم من الواضح
ان الشعب الامريكي بما فيها المحافظين او
الجمهوريين المعتدلين لا يريد ان تتدخل
الحكومه في هذه القرارات الخاصه حتى لو
رفعت المحكمه الدستوريه الحاضر على ذلك
طيب مرح حتى في الولايات تفضل تفضل
شيء يعني
حق المراه كبير جدا يعني ان تكون ولايه
مثل كنزس او كانتا ويقولون بكل وضوح وياتي
الناخبين باعداد كبيره فوق المعتاد
ليقولوا ان المراه حق في هذه الولايات
المحافظه شيء كبير وانا اتفق مع الاستاذ
حافظ ان هذا يدل انه هناك صوت معتدل لا
يزال في الحزب الجمهوري رغم الخوف من
التطرف
الاصوات التي
انا انا في اعتقادي انه كلما زاده هذه
الاصوات المتطرفه كلما كان افضل لان الناس
سترى بوضوح خطوره هذه الشخصيات خطوره
الشخصيات التي مثل ترفض موضوع عن
الانتخابات كانت عادله ثم زالت تسر على
نظريه الخزعبلات الذي يظهر بها ترامب بان
الانتخابات الماضيه سرقت الى اخر هذا
الكلام ولكن انا صحيح كلامك صحيح في كنزس
في كنتاكي ايضا في مشيكان التي غيرت
دستورها تغيير كامل لكسمح وتحمي حق المراه
مع انه مش جن اتجهت الى الى الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات الماضيه همم
عفوا يبدو ان الشبكه ضعيفه في منزلك او
ربما اجهزه اخرى مرتبطه بالانترنت
الاتصال بك
حتى نصحح الصوت لان هناك تقطع في صوتك ولا
تقول بعد ذلك توفيق ظلمني ولم
استمتع بهذا بهذا النفق
الاتصال مرحلي
اول شيء حافظ هو شخص مخضرم بالحياه
الامريكيه ومسياسات الامريكيه ونحن اصدقاء
منذ عشرات سنوات
يا استاذ حافظ يا صديقي العزيز هناك قضايا
ملحها الان اليوميه تتعلق بالمعيشه
المواطن الامريكي قضيه الاجهاض ليست رقم
واحد الان على جمده رب الاسره الذي يعاني
الان في تامين الغذاء همم
باسعاره المعقوله لعائلته
التضخم الذي حدث في عهد اخليه يكفي موضوع
الاجهاض صحيح قانون بس هناك اجتهادات
سماحه
للولايات ان تقوم باشهادات الخاصه
وحدث هناك اجتهادات بقانون يعني اهم شيء
بتاعه السياسيه الامريكيه
انها متغيره انها متطوره انها لا يوجد
فيها شيء مطلق ولا يمكن تغييره يمكن على
طول ايجاد قراءات واجتهادات في القوانين
والقرارات فيما يتعلق بالحياه العامه
والحياه الناس الان هناك قضايا ملحنه
نستطيع الان نضعها خلفنا
هناك هذا الخطاب الذي يتحدث على ان مثلا
بعض المواضيع زي حقوق المراه لم تكن على
اللي هي دافع اساسي في الانتخابات اتبتت
الانتخابات امبارح انه هذا كلام غير صحيح
لان كثير من الناس خرجوا خصوصا
لمحاوله حمايه حقوق المراه بما فيهم كثير
من من النساء الجمهوريه فهذا كان موضوع
قوي انا عارف ان الحزب الجمهوري حاول على
مدى الاسابيع الماضيه ان يقلل من اهميه
هذا الموضوع ويحاول دفع بموضوع الغلاء
اكثر ولكن في الاخير الموضوع الاقتصادي لم
يكن يعني
ناس هنا ليسوا اغبياء يعرفوا ان الغلاء هو
جزء من ظاهره عالميه ليست لا يمكن ان
الواحد يلوم بيضا مثلا في ارتفاع اسعار
النفط مع انه حاول يعني الان الولايات
المتحده عندها اقل الاسعار
هذه الارقام
نلوم سياسه بعيدا وتعاملهم مع الحلفاء في
المنطقه واهم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الطريقه السناب اللي استعمل فيها مع همم
شغل عظمى هي في المنطقه هي
الاسناب كان بالعكس سناب كان من السعوديه
مش من بايدون حاول كل ما يستطيع ذهب سعودي
وليس وليس بايده تفضلي
كانت رده فعل في السعوديه فعلا على تصرف
بدات فيه دعاره بعيد لانه وليست فعلا هذا
رقم واحد همم انا لم اقل حافظ انا لم اقول
ان موضوع الاجهاض ليس موضوع عن هاما انا
قلت هناك
حسب الجمهوري حاول ان يروج لهذه الفكره لم
يقول لك انت حاول فيما يتعلق بقضيه المراه
والاجها
تهميش القبيل حقيقه ههه نعم نعم انا لا
اخذه شخصي عم بحكي انا عم بحكي هون واحد
حسبيه يعني لا اخذه بشكل شخصي بس خليني
اقول لك موضوع معين انا صوتت بالابسانتيه
يعني بالتصويت مبكر كان في اقبال شديد جدا
من الديمقراطيه اللي واقفين بالله انت
بعديه يعني عم ياخذوا الورقه الزرقاء في
التصفيه المبكر وانا استغربت جدا من هذه
الظاهره همم ديمقراطيين لعبوها صح راحوا
على التصويت المبكر حتى
يؤمنواصلاته انا اعتقد من
انا استغرب عم اقول لك صحيح كلامك 100%
انا استغربت انه كان في اللاين طويل على
على
الزرقاء يعني الورقه الزرقاء الزرقاء وعلى
فكره دائما ما في وهذا خطا جمهوريين دائما
لا يوجد
فالنتين يعني متطوعين على المراكز
الانتخابيه دائما ديموقراطين
بدي دعايه مرحبا
ملتويه اخرى حول التلاعب بها في
الانتخابات
جديده للانتخابات لذلك مثلا
يقلبوا الولايه الى درجه كبيره لان تصبح
جمهوريه لانهم تلاعبوا بالدستريكس يعني
مقاطعات في
الماضيه لذلك المشكله الاساسيه عند
الجمهوريين انهم ما زالوا الى درجه كبيره
حزب يعتمد على طيف واحد من المجتمع
الامريكي وهو طيف مهم وهو اييي ال ال ال
ال ال البيض في الولايات المتحده الذين
كانوا يعانوا من
التهميش او الاقصاء ولكن هذا بدا يتغير
لسببين
اولا بايضا استطاع ان يرجع كثير من هؤلاء
همم البيض الامريكيين متوسطين داخل الذين
كانوا مقتنعين ايام اوباما الى اخره انهم
اخسوا وهم شو يعني اصبحت الولايات المتحده
تتحدث على التنوع الجنسي والتنوع الديني
وانا القبول في امورهم يعتبروها غير
اخلاقيه زي همم
الجيز واللازم الى اخره
مساء استطاع
بايد ان يرجعوهم لانه في الاخير منهم جزء
منهم الان متى راينا ذلك ايضا في
بنسلفانيا
الطيف الابيض
المتوسطين داخل حتى شكلها يعني هذا رجل
عادي همم تراه لهذا الجزء من
الديمقراطين مبتدا
طيب طيب
تحدث عن مساله التدخل ونحن نعرف تاريخ
الولايات المتحده عاده عندما يتعلق الامر
بالتضخم وبجيب الامريكيين فانا الناخب
يصوت بشكل مكثف للحزب الاخر لماذا لم يحصل
ذلك هذه المره علما بان التضخم هو الان ب
8.5%
اسمح لي قبل ان تجيب على هذا السؤال ان
اضيف نقطه لمقاله الاستاذ
وهي ان الحزب الجمهوري لا يفوز فقط
بتغيير ال ال ترسيم الخطوط بين المقاطعات
ولكن ايضا بمنع الاشخاص من الاقليات في
ولايات مثلجه من الوصول لكي يستطيعوا
الانتساب وهذا الشيء يدل على ان هذا الحزب
او جزء منه جزء من الحزب لا يظن ان
باستطاعته ان يفوز
بقوانين نزيهه بالسماح للجميع بالانتخاب
وهذا لان معظم الولايات المتحده
الاقليات
وهذا شيء يزيد
عفوا
لا قليه في فلوريدا سوتت لسان الحزب
الجمهوري
نعم ففلور الثانيه
يعني هذا الكلام غير مقبول عندما يفوز
الجمهوريون عن هناك مشكله
بالتصويت عندما يفوز ديمقراطيون يا عيني
الامور كلها سليمه
[ضحك]
بالنتائج لم يهدد ابدا بهذا من الاعتراف
[موسيقى]
نعم
ثلاثه الاف ثلاثه الاف ثلاثه الاف ثلاثه
الاف من المرشحين قالوا لن نعترف بالنتائج
مسبقا
لا
لاسبوع الماضي عنوانه حتى انت يا كلينتون
طلعت وقالت تصريح على السي بي اس قالت اذا
فازوا الجمهوريه فنحن نشكك بالانتخابات
يعني عملت مثل ما كان وعم بيهاجموا ترامب
اربع سنين عملت نفس الشيء
والتطرف هذا اللي عم يحكوا عنه زميلين
العزيزان حافظ وسيد ناديه التطرف موجود
عند
البروجستيفال ده بشكل مخيف والتطرف موجود
ايضا عند الجمهوريين هناك دائما اعتدال
وبالانس بالحياه السياسيه الامريكيه الان
بعد ان شاء الله عوده الجمهوريين
للاغلبيين في المجلسين سيتحقق البلد رئيس
ديموقراطي في البيت الابيض
شعارات موجود في مجزي شيوخ والنواب وهذا
يحقق فعلا المعادله الامريكيه الديمقراطيه
لان زبيد لن يحدث يعني كل ما يمكن
الرئيس هو الذي يقرر وليس الكونغرس على
سبيل المثال في مجال مساعدات الى دول
الخارج فان الرئيس هو الذي يقرر يعني
المساعدات لن تتوقف على سبيل المثال
ههه سيد سيد
لا يوجد شيك على بياض
للكرونيا حين يصل الجمهوريين كيفن مكارتي
كان واضح جدا لا شيك على بياض سيعملون على
انهاء الحريق بين حرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
الامريكيه دائما كانت في يد الرئيس اينعم
دور كبير في الميزانيه فهم نعم يستطيع ان
يضغطوا على الرئيس في موضوع الميزانيه
ولكن
اهميه الرئاسه الامريكيه السيد توفيق هي
داخليا بالنسبه للولايات المتحده اي نعم
الجميع يتفق ان السياسه الخارجيه هي في يد
الرئيس لذلك انتخاب الرئيس يمكن اعتقد
دائما ان هو بقيه العالم خصوصه في الوطن
العربي يجب ان يكون لهم حق الانتخاب في
الولايات المتحده لانهم يتاثرون الرئيس
الامريكي
لكن انا بس بس بس صوته عن بعد بدون تاشيره
لانه صعب يعطيهم تاشيره كلهم
ههه
هو سيحدث هذا التغيير التي تتحدثين عليه
لان الارقام ما زالت لم تنتهي يعني اي نعم
سيستطيع الاغلب في اغلب الظنون ان الايام
القادمه ستقول ان الجمهوريين سيستطيع ان
يكون اغلبيه في الكونجرس ولكنها ستكون
اغلبيه همم ضئيله جدا يعني لن تتعدى يمكن
10 افراد وهذا يعني انهم سيضطروا ان
يتعاملوا او يتعاونوا مع الديمقراطيين
للوصول لاي نتائج حقيقيه في السنه ما زال
الامر غير الواضح
حافظ حافظ
لا يكون القرار بلون واحد
عاطف يتعاون لا يكون القرار بلون واحد انا
اقول لك اذا الديمقراطين استمروا مثلا في
موضوع همم اتفاق النووي مع ايران هذه
كارثه ليس فقط للامريكيين هذه كارثه
للعالم يعني الرئيس بايدا يريد ان يدفع
بهذا الاتفاق باي شكل ممكن لانه المدرسه
اوباما
لا اظن ابدا ان هذا سيحدث لان ما يحدث في
ايران الان هو ان الشعب الايراني يحتف
ويقول لا نريد هذه الحكومه الاسلاميه وهذا
سيغير جميع الموازين الان يوجد ضغط كبير
في الاتحاد
ولكن هذا يحدده نوع الحكومه في ايران اذا
سقط ويبدو انه سيسقط اذا سقط
الحزب الحاكم في ايران فهذا سيغير موازين
كبيره جدا اذا اصبح هناك دوله ديمقراطيه
في ايران هذا سيغير موازين النحو
الداخليه
اعتقد ان الوصول الى توافق مع ايران شيء
ممتاز وجوهري ويجب ان يحدث بعد 40 سنه او
اكثر من العداوه مع ايران ايران لن تذهب
الى اي مكان اخر ايران قوه استراتيجيه في
منطقتنا اردنا
ايران دوله لها تاريخها لها حضارتها لها
توازنها يجب التعامل معها باحترام
لكن الشعله الاجنبيه
انا بتكلم على امراه
وعدتقد انه يجب
ان تحترم ايران وان تحترم همم حقوقها
خصوصا عندما يكون هناك سلاح نووي في
اسرائيل يعني يجب ان نكون واضحين اعتقد ان
الدول العربيه التي تعادي ايران هي الدول
تخطئ خطا استراتيجي في حق المنطقه ككل
الامر الاخر
لكلامك سيد ناديه انا لا اعتقد انه سيكون
هناك تغيير في ايران اعتقد انه ان هذه ال-
ال- المظاهرات مظاهرات لها حق ويجب ان
تحترم ونعم تطالب بحقوق بسيطه وهو حقوق
الحياه الخاصه وحقوق المراه في ان تلبس
حجاب او لا تلبس حجاب كما نتحدث هنا في
امريكا ان المراه لها الحق في الاجهاض ام
لا هذه حقوق واضحه انسانيه يجب احترامها
ولكني لا اعتقد ان النظام سيسقط
بسبب هذه المظاهرات اي نعم هناك اطراف
تريد ان تستغل هذه المظاهرات لاسقاط
النظام ولكن اعتقد ان هو شيء يعني هيكون
ما اساء لا بس التوفيق نقطه احنا شوفنا ما
حدث في العراق في ليبيا في اليمن في سوريا
كلما استعمل الشعبي
كل ما استعملت الاوراق
خلونا في امريكا يا جماعه
اريد
مرحالك يعني حتى نكون في الايطار لان
تبعنا هذه الحمله
بكثير من الاهتمام حتى في الخارج حمله
الانتخابات يعني ان كانت النتيجه التي
سنصل اليها بعد سنتين هو ان يترشح ترامب
ويعيد بعيد انت ترشحه يعني بيني وبينك
يعني هذه هي النتيجه التي ستبدا
من جديد
اعتقد اننا
خليني جنبك
هذا سؤال المليون دولار جيد جدا السؤال
يعني
اولا اولا نحن يعني معظم اطياف الحزب همم
الجمهوري لا تريد ولا ان توافق على ترشح
ترامب انا لو سيرشح نفسه لكن بتصفيات
الاخيره لن يصلك ترامب انا بعد اعتقد هذا
الشيء شخصي طبعا اعتقد ان
للوزير خارج الاصبع
حظ كبير جدا في نيل تشريح ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري بالنسبه الى الرئيس الرئيس
يعني اليوم يقول صراحه ان الجمهوريين
وطبعا هو نوع من الاستفسار من سينان هذا
الجمهوريين يفضلون ديسانتس على
اكثر من 70%
اروقه حزب الجمهوري ولا سيما المعتديلين
لن يسمحوا لترامب بالوصول الى الترشيح
النهائي لان هناك عده مرشحين سيختار الحزب
واحد منهم هلا بالنسبه لبعيدن بالنسبه
لبعيد
استطلاع راي اليوم لا اذكر مين قام به
تحديدا لكن موجود اليوم على المسان يقول
ان معظم الامريكيين لا يريدوا ان يترشح
لسبب رئيسي الى العلاقه سي بي اس صحيح همم
لسببين همم عمره
مشجع ولا عمره مشجع فلم يصلون
ايران
شكرا لك
بس لا عنجد بدي اقول بموضوعيه وبدون تحيز
لحدا حافظ كان عم يحكي على موضوع ايران يا
حافظ تتذكر الحقائب الفلوس النقديه
دولارات النقديه اللي راحت لايران وترتفعت
العقوبات عندنا على ايام اوباما هل هذه
صوره الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا الذي
يريد من رفع العقوبات على ايران هذا الذي
نريد
لو ما تراخي اوباما لما اقتربت ايران هلا
من تصنيع السلاح النووي ايران
امريكا ولا حدا لان اصلا على ابواب تصنيع
سلاح النووي ينتهي
وباكستان
واسرائيل كلهم همم قوتنا لماذا مش ايران
يا حافظ باكستان ما عندها ميليشيات عم
تبعثها على سوريا والعراق وبغداد وبغداد
واليما وتقول انا احتليت اربع ساعات عواصم
عربيه ما عندنا
بالمنطقه كلها مشيره
على مدى 40 سنه في المدى العشر سنوات
الماضيه اسوا الاعداء الذين واجهتهم ايران
بالتوفيق
اعتقد ان اوباما
اعتقد انه اوباما كان رجل وكان رئيس ممتاز
جدا سيتذكره التاريخ ويتذكره الامريكان
لحد اليوم فلا اعتقد انه متى اعتقد انه
اساسي
اذا كان لا يستطيع الجمهوريين ان يوقفوا
هذا التيار المتطرفه
الولايات المتحده ويعتقد ان الانتخابات
تشرف بهذه الطرق العبيطه ومستعد ان يخرج
وحتى يهاجم مبنى الكونجرس وان الكثير من
الجمهوريه داخل الكونجرس نفسك ما زالوا لم
يتشجعوا بالوقوف وحمايه
النظام الديمقراطي الامريكي بغض النظر عن
منهم طيب هذا هو ما سيقتل الحزب الجمهوري
ناديه
نعم يقنع يقنع الجمهوريين انفسهم بان بيض
اداءه ضعيف جدا جدا جدا وسوف تكون هناك
موجه عارمه حمراء والذي حدث ان الناخذ
الامريكي قال كلمته بصوت عالي كبيرا انه
لاول مره منذ 20 سنه في السياسه الامريكيه
الحزب الحاكم يحافظ تقريبا
رغم جميع ما يقوله جمهوريه الانفسهم
اداءه يظهر في الانتخابات انهم لم يخسروا
بشكل كبير هذا الدعم
المزيد من التاريخ يصنع في الحزب الجمهوري
لاول مره حاكم من اصول افريقيه في ميرندا
ااه تم تغيير مقاعد كانت في الحزب
الجمهوري اصبحت في الحزب الديمقراطي
هذه الانتخابات هي اكبر دليل ان هناك
ولسياساته وان حتى الجمهوريه انفسهم يسووا
ضد اييي حركات
حزبهم بمثل في حقوق المراه وامره اخرى
كاميرا
لا يحبون لا يحبونها كما ربما يكون هناك
لا شك همم تحيز ضد المراه ولو في الا وعيد
شخصيه من البيت الابيض يعني ما
ههه
هناك تحيز ضد المراه
يعني لو هم الاثنين همم دخله اللي في
التنافس الرئاسي سنصبح يعني في دائره من
العجز يعني واحد منهم فوق ال 80 والثاني
خلاص 80 سنه فده غيره عقلاني لا اعتقد
انهم الاثنين سيكون في الانتخابات القادمه
ولا اعتقد انك كامله هارس حتى لو حاول
ستستطيع ان تنجح اعتقد ان انا سنرى شخصيات
جد انا اعتقد مرح مرح مرح
ونسمحوا لي ان اقول انا مرشحه فرجينيا
سيده مهاجره اسمها كارينا لبسما مهاجره من
اوكرينيا
يقدم النساء الى المقدمه همم
يدعم الشباب في الدخول في الحزب والترشيح
الشباب الحزب الجمهوري ليس نزيه عن
الاخطاء لكن يحاول ان يطور نفسه موجود
انا اريدك ان تكوني انت المرشحه وانا
مستعد ان ان ان انقل الى الجمهوري
سافعل سافعل ذلك
في عام 2014
من الحسبين نعتقد ان هذه قوه ال- ال- ال-
ال- ال- الجاليه العربيه في الولايات
المتحده ان عندها فرص حقيقيه في ان تتقدم
نعرف مثلا بمؤسسه اسمها ام جي والتي
استطاعت ان ان تسجل اكثر من مليون ناخد
مسلم في الولايات المتحده على مدى سنتين
الماضيتين هذا شيء انا اعتز به واعتقد انه
هو هذا ما ما ما يؤيد ان هذه الولايات كما
نعرفها نحن مش كيف ما يراها الاخرين من
الخارج انها همم دوله تستطيع ان تقبل
بالاخرين دوله همم تضم الاخرين مش زي بقيه
الدول الاوروبيه التي تحاول اقصاء
الجاليات العربيه والاسلاميه
اخباريه كيف تؤثر الانتخابات النصفيه على
علاقه الولايات المتحده بالخارج هل يمكن
لان نسمع الان ان الحزب الجمهوري من بين
وسماته حتى جمهوريه لا اخفي عنك انه
كمان يمارس الرياضه مع عيسى باحا ومن
الحزب الجمهوري يقول لي انه صوت دائما
لترامب ولجماعه ترامب لانه لا يهمني
النعطي مساعدتنا الخارج ما يهمني هو ان
تصل هذه المساعدات الى الامريكيين تفضل
[تصفيق]
والمس انفورميشن
الاخبار الكاذبه ويوجد دلائل الكبيره ان
روسيا كان لها ضلع كبير جدا في نتائج
الانتخابات الامريكيه في 2016 ومنذ ذلك
الحين وهي تحاول ان تتلاعب بشكل كبير في
الولايات المتحده
بنشر الاكاذيب وخلق حسابات غير موجوده
ولكن لذلك هذا جزء من الاسنان الخارجيه
لانه حتى في العالم العربي مثلا تقوم
الاولاد شركات كبيره في الولايات المتحده
بالتعاون مع حكومات سلطه قويه قمعيه
تستخدم التكنولوجيا الغربيه لمنع حقوق
الانسان
لمنع التطور الديمقراطي الحقيقي من من قلب
الشعب من قلب الشعوب العربيه وهذه مشكله
التوازن والاستقرار والامان على المسرح
الدولي
ويوجد هناك اتجاه للحزب الجمهوري يختلف عن
الحزب الديمقراطي الحزب الديمقراطي بشكل
عام بالاضافه الى احتضانه للاقليات بشكل
اكبر بكثير من الحزب الجمهوري هو انا اجد
هو اكثر رحمه على الامريكيين داخليا يريد
ان ان يكون هناك اكثر مثلا تامين توفير
خدمات للاطفال
وبنفس الوقت للخارج وهناك الحزب
الديمقراطي اكثر
الخارج لتامين المساعدات الخارجيه هي
النفس هي نفس الفلسفه التي في رايي بها
رحمه اكثر من فقط المصالح الامريكيه
البحته والتي تضر العالم باجمعه لان
امريكا تقود العالم وهي جزء من العالم
في نهايه البرنامج
شكرا لالك سيد حافظ تحدث عن امر مهم جدا
المهاجرون العرب الامريكيون العرب الان
موجودين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمسلمين بشكل عام وايضا الراي العام
لعربي مهم جدا ان يكون ان نستهدف هذه
الشريحه في المستقبل لتنقرض اكثر في
الحياه الامريكيه اتحدث عن الامريكيون من
اصل عربي والامريكيون المسلمون لهذا السبب
قمنا بانشاء منصه تتعودتها استغل فتره
وجودي في البيت الابيض كموراسله
واقمنا هذه المنصه باللغه العربيه تقدم
الخبر الامريكي للقارئ العالم هناك من
المهاجرين العرب يفضلون ان يقراوا
بالعربيه حتى الان موجودين في امريكا هذه
الشريحه يجب ان تخرج في الحياه الامريكيه
وان يكون لها صوت او ايضا حافظ تماما بهذه
النقطه وان شاء الله نصل الى اكبر عدد من
هذه الشريحه بدات حافظ بقى
مرح بدات حملتها الانتخابيه تفضل الحافظ
باختصار وانا مشجع لها
واليد السخيه عليه لان خرجت الشربانه
او اي ذلك او عيد ان شاء الله حتى
الدكتوره ناديه ان ان ان ان تدخل
الانتخابات اعتقد سؤالك على السياسه
الخارجيه مهمه
اتفضل انا اعتقد ان هناك همم في الفكر
الامريكي عموما عبر التاريخ هناك همم يعني
زي ما بيقول همم قوتين واحده هي قوه تريد
الانعزال عن العالم وهذا يرجع الى التاريخ
الولايات المتحده والهجره من اوروبا
والفرار من من الدكتاتوريه الكنيسه
والملوك في اوروبا
هناك ايضا الطرف الاخر الذي يعي ان
الولايات المتحده لا تستطيع ان تعيش في في
عزله لان هذا النظام العالمي كلنا لان
نعيش فيه رضينا بها ولم نرضى كان همم نتاج
من الامريكيين حقيقه من بدايه القرن ال 20
كل الاجسام الدوليه كل النظام الدولي كله
كام
تصميمه من الولايات المتحده لذلك اعتقد
خروج الولايات المتحده من العالم مش بس
يضر بالولايات المتحده ولكن يضر بالعلم ان
ليس هناك لحد الان بديل عن هذا النظام طيب
الشكر في الختام من واشنطن مراحل الوقايه
عضو الحزب الجمهوري الشكر من كونزاز اصلي
ناديه
وشكر ايضا لحفظ الغويويل من معهد الدراسات
الدوليه في جامعه جونس هوبكنز الشكر لفريق
البرنامج امسيا مريحه للجميع